that's what i'm saying jake do you have
any idea how to ollie
okay
so we both floated at the same time
oh ah what is this
your camera's rolling you have to catch
up with jake because the prank's on
right now what do you mean oh snap oh
snap
you fell for it
free crap alert dude see this toothpaste
got me again how does it do that we got
two different electric skateboards in
the mail
which one of these electric skateboards
is the best
and
is it better than a onewheel well
okay let's see next way with an e
brandon your expert opinion
what makes a good electric skateboard
okay for me i want an electric
skateboard that can go like 20 miles
removable battery packs would be clutch
but if you have a large amount this is
actually like really nice 20 miles an
hour if you can go 20
but yeah that's that's a good rule of
thumb if you can go 20 miles at 20 miles
an hour that's that's a pretty solid
board i've got the v1 boosted board and
they advertise that that will go like
six seven miles but really if you're
going at full speed you can get maybe
three or four miles out of it there are
the belt driven systems where basically
you have a motor driving a pulley which
drives a belt which drives the wheels
you get a lot more torque you can
typically go a lot faster what's great
about hub motors is that
because of the low resistance you can
still ride it very easily whoa
like skateboard
that's how you ride it here's the other
board it's a max find so this one this
one you have a chance of doing an ollie
with
so this is also a hub motor this is
what's called a single motor drive
system one motor instead of two motors
it means you get a little less torque a
little less acceleration but you
typically get further range
yeah you don't use as much power and so
you can typically go farther but you
also usually go slower
that's interesting
oh
it technically has a reverse function so
that's another thing i like about the
boosted board is that it can go full
speed either direction at any moment in
time as opposed to this thing where you
actually have to flip a switch to change
the direction
he'll figure it out eventually the max
fine could potentially go further than
the x-way the blue one might be able to
go further than the orange one because
the blue one only has one tire that it
needs to motorize but it might also have
a much smaller battery i might yeah
hey
there you go
did that count
i forgot what i was saying that little
guy will be able to go 15 miles an hour
which is the same speed as the one wheel
whoa orange one let's see top speed 20
miles an hour okay so it'll go about 10
miles both electric boards will be able
to go about 10 miles which in real world
means it'll go about eight but
simultaneously really interesting and
annoying about this x-way board this
this little rubber thing is like
practically impossible to get out oh my
god because it
i can't get there we go okay the
charging port and it's fairly clever
it's magnetic kind of like the mag safe
chargers on the max there we go this is
annoying this little rubber thing is
annoying but this is cool so check this
out
that's not a snap that was a spark
[Music]
dude so
we're not allowed to prank red anymore
no we're not and we're not allowed to
it's that we
have decided to find a workaround
precisely now carmichael has been
watching a lot of
jake and logan paul my boy's a beast i
gotta glock him up yeah yeah he actually
convinced me to watch a video of each of
them
i didn't drink a lot of that green tea
man it's not your cat jake walks by and
he's like he [ __ ] hates those guys he
hates the paul brothers i don't give a
shniply about what people think about me
when he walked by my computer and you
saw me watching it he like legitimately
got angry like he got frustrated not
because of what i was watching was
because i was watching it signed in on
sam and nico
and he was like how dare you people just
take situations way too seriously the
point is so what are we gonna do swap
his desktop background with jake paul
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks to skillshare for sponsoring this
video it's a different kind of video and
that it contains information you may
actually find useful you see it all
started a few years ago when i wanted to
learn piano
i kind of sounded like that a few years
ago i bought an antique piano from our
landlord steve for a hundred dollars
however after moving it around for a few
years i've got it right here in my home
where it belongs lately i've been
playing what little i know to my
daughter eliza
[Music]
she really enjoys it she enjoys music
it's a bond we've created together
so it got me thinking why don't i learn
more about piano and teach her the
basics fundamentals and the tips and
tricks and maybe when she gets older she
can teach me a thing or two to do this
i've been using skillshare it's an
online learning community with 15 000
courses in design cinematography music
and more and also you can learn from
anywhere download the mobile app on
android or iphone and learn from classes
even when you're offline if you're a
creator you can even teach a class
yourself premium memberships give you
access to all the courses for just
around 10 bucks a month so is it worth
it if you like teaching yourself new
skills and you don't have time to attend
school or formal classes skillshare is
definitely worth it or you can buy a
drink at my piano bar
just remember
the first 300 people to click the link
below will get two months free
you're welcome
[Music]
yeah 25 miles an hour is like
realistically the maximum speed you want
to go on a skateboard this thing you
cannot hear at all
how cool would it be yeah everyone had
one and go to shinsengui for lunch come
back take as long as walking to stevens
talking about day of my life man i ride
this stuff every day it's all kind of
hitting me now la is so automobile
centric but but with one of these
that all changes the max fine this board
is very very cheap or is 350 bucks but
it's advertised at going 15 miles an
hour and i think it's going half that uh
hey hey hey oh we gotta run away huge
problem you have it in cruise control
and it stays there this is a recipe for
disaster
i'm not doing anything
we're back ren brought his boosted board
we're going to test out both of them to
see which one is king a lot about the
boosted board i put several hundred
miles on this thing very lightweight is
very fast there's like 22 miles an hour
like
can't do that on this guy no
trucks
trucks the boosted board has two motors
on the outside back here belt driven
system to the wheels over here where the
motor is inside the wheel the remotes
are very very similar this is the
booster remote this is the x-way remote
can't do anything unless you have the
trigger held down where's this guy you
can just go for it
one thing i've noticed about the hub
motor system on the x-ray is that it
gets very very hot um i noticed on the
boosted board that it has heat sinks on
the side after riding this one the x-ray
for miles and miles and miles that is
when the true tests will be shown about
how it stands up to the miles that ren's
already put on the boosted board because
clearly this thing's built to last we
see some problems coming through with
the wheels and things like that and the
heat coming through on the x-way
i i say now let's actually ride them and
test them out
[Music]
so we both floated at the same time
oh
ah
and now he's going faster because i've
tapped out on speed
i'm bad
three two one go
yeah a little faster
a little faster
it's gonna catch up
i'm still going full speed
catches up and passes me what is this
the boosted board is way louder
[Music]
[Music]
remember it's like chinchin three two
one three
two
what there's cards
that's why i was doing this lower count
say the countdown keep it consistent
that's what was going to do
three
two
one
three two one go precise
three two one go
[Applause]
if i if i was presented the boosted
board and the x-way simultaneously i
would probably still choose the x-way
because the boosted board is older it
doesn't go as boosted board two
life of a futurist
jake's going to be back any second
you have to catch up with jake as the
pranks on right now what do you mean
we changed his desktop background to
jake paul oh snap oh snap the prank
there's a prank okay that's what the
prank is they changed his background and
jake
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh no
it is lit every single day bro
we did it
for i come back to my computer i open it
up and i'm like and i'm first i'm
thinking oh the screen's already turned
off i wonder why that is and guess what
this is waiting for me your favorite
youtube creator i'm
seriously getting sick just like you
said you told me that was your favorite
influencer then influencer wow
i had nothing to do with this story i
found out about this about 30 seconds
ago i thought this was nurse
you're gonna lie to me and tell me this
idea wasn't yours this idea was not mine
[Laughter]
you fell for it
[Applause]
son you gotta got so hard
is that a fake background wallpaper
switch you said you're getting wrenched
and eventually say mine yes
that was deep
[Music]
you